hi I'm Rachel and this is my friend
Dylan and we're here today to break down
how to do some at home workouts when
it's really crappy outside and cold and
icy and such side Rian's like right
behind your thighs and then just try to
point your toes keep drawing the abs in
bring the legs to table top and let's
just try one at a time keeping the abs
engaged kick one leg out Stephen Kate
both legs out one hand off oh man good
both hands off amazing so we're gonna
start with some bar moves feet are
parallel lift your heels as high as you
can like you're balancing something on
top of your head and then just bend your
knees little pulses down for five don't
stink that butt out then we're going to
go down two counts go all the way down
tuck your tailbone come all the way back
up good narrowly position so just
channel your inner ballarino your the
lift your heels up about two inches
outside hand on the hip same concept
right like you're balancing something on
the head come down halfway little pulses
down go try to tuck the tailbone zip the
abs in and up pause right there press
the knees back for five kick your right
leg back and keep your hips square just
lift and lower that right leg then you
can also take it full range so take this
hose down like you're tapping five
o'clock on a clock and then lift it
right back up
so lift up hold right there tuck your
tailbone again perfect yes keep that now
just squeeze your butt to lift your leg
45 again squeeze for exhale tighten that
quad straighten the leg three two one
push push push push push do you feel it
in the butt straighten your arms again
tuck your tailbone again there we go